what's up believe nation it was really
good be honest it was really good of
course other way if it wasn't really
good we'd still be shooting today I am
doing a photo shoot with celebrity
photographer Matt Barnes and I'm taking
you guys on my journey with me
[Music]
what's up elimination hope you're having
an amazing weekend so I am off to do a
photo shoot with celebrity photographer
Matt Barnes he's a photographer in
Toronto there's a lot of awesome shoots
and this came as a result of Jay Rhys a
guy on my team who's been with me for a
long time was getting frustrated that
there was a lack of pictures of me that
he wanted to use for social media and
different campaigns and it seems to be
the same pictures over and over and over
and over again so I don't blame him and
and I agree so he decided to book this
session
Matthewson charges 2500 bucks for a
session and so we're heading down to his
studio we're gonna meet him see what
he's like and hopefully take some shots
I think he promises at least five good
pictures and so over the past week I've
been slowly working on restricting my
calories just a little bit making sure
lost lose a couple pounds and have my
hair cut last night so I'm ready to do
the shoot see how it goes
[Music]
so I'm here I think I'm about 20 minutes
early just paid for parking side note
I'm always early if I'm if I'm not early
I'm dead or my flight got canceled I
just like being early for things you
never know how long does it take you to
get somewhere and I don't like letting
people down so I'm always early so I'm
going to Wow I think that's the building
go inside I tried to find Matt and have
some fun now one of the things about
Matt is he has a mix of styles he can go
super corporate and traditional headshot
stuff but he also has some really edgy
offbeat crazy stuff so we'll see we'll
see how much he stretches my comfort
zone today the goal from Jia rise was to
have pictures that we could use on a
regular basis for social media content
so that's typically not the crazy edgy
stuff and Matt can go crazy so I'm
excited I'm excited maybe one of the
five will be something crazy we'll see
all I'm going the wrong way finding this
place is job number one
[Music]
wait format so went to the bathroom
gotta fix my hair right you know make
sure every piece is uh perfect there we
go now we're ready to shoot here comes
the J rise there we go we're vlogging it
today what's up man
I told believe nation this was a gift
from you
so explain why that's it all right
feeling the love I'm ready to rock what
did you bring
well you've brought food too dude oh man
look at this Wow I was telling the
community that the past couple days have
been cutting the calories a little bit
drop the couple's with a poundage yes to
shoot just like just for this shoot
right and so now I got I got I got some
treats maybe I'll do these post post
videos
good what's up a leave nation check this
out we got some sandwiches some cookies
all these this smells like ginger
cookies man and something else in there
I'm diggin it I'm excited
this is the man Matt how long you been
here I've been here since 2002 so it's a
long time yeah nice what what would you
describe what you do okay I'm done
Jay's gonna get going in okay how was my
shoot man it was really good
be honest all right there we go oh look
there's a preview it's there you go
I like it all right I like it well I
hope it looks like me
[Music]
wrap it up bye guys
see you soon all right nice we're done
what do you think Jay amazing dude
you're a new man we're excited to see
the pictures they look pretty good on
the computer
we'll see how they turn out when that we
get them live haven't done a photo shoot
in the wild so that was a good
experience Thank You Jay rise whoa
appreciate the love and thank you guys
for joining us on this quick journey
much love
we believe in you continue to believe
and whatever your one word is much love
I will see you soon